all right Derek how are you doing Derek
uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally um I'm a nato in Los
Angeles California I grew up in South
Central Los Angeles tell me about your
family growing up oh we're all grown up
at first
uh it was wonderful you know we had a
just a normal family you know mother
father grandmother grandfather
but when crack cocaine came into the
neighborhoods that destroyed everything
and the mid 80s were a transition for me
because I had to grow up fast you know
it I had to feed my family at the age of
10 you know because my parents were not
there emotionally
they were there physically but crack had
them so crack raised me you know crack
was my mother my father cracked you know
supported me you know and also destroyed
me
at the same time
so it was hard but you know how are you
supporting your family at 10 years old
well at the age of 10 I was pumping
gasoline or cutting Lawns and taking out
people's trash whatever I had to do just
to put food on the table just get food
on the table what were your mom and
daddy doing crack cocaine yeah which
means not much else
yeah so there were
they were they weren't there they
weren't there you know
for us emotionally it was they were
detached from reality really crack
cocaine had a strong hold on
bills weren't getting paid food wasn't
being bought clothes wasn't being bought
you know we had to
had to make do of what we had and I
couldn't take it anymore you know so I
wound up selling dope
and that didn't help the situation
because it just brought more problems
finish High School oh absolutely
but you know
high school and what I learned in those
three years I have not really used you
know
so the streets pretty much raised me
you've been living you're homeless now I
am currently homeless how long you been
like that uh since 2014.
after a brief stint in prison for
something I didn't do
I uh
was disenfranchised basically and I'm
all sorts of income that I was getting I
was no longer I could no longer get it
you know so
I had to do what I had to do so I would
sell dope just to you know make ends
meet until I found a job and once I once
I became employed and I'll stop doing
the Dirty Work
starting to you know do more positive
things and just
taking it a step at a time trying to you
know get my life back in order
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life when you were young
oh well
I raised my family I raised my children
you know it was
that was do you have kids of your own I
I have a kid I have two children two
biological children can you raise them
yeah and I raised about 17 others how's
that uh well they were uh children are
already there in a relationship when I
started it and so I just you know took
to them and I never treated them any
different from my own children
you know I gave them guidance protection
love you know
I was you know a father you know and I
took my job seriously
in your prison time how much time did
you do oh well
the first time I went to prison I did
two years
the second time I did nine months
so it was low level level one you know
nothing major I haven't killed anyone
yeah
and yet you had Jarvis before yes I've
always I've always worked you know uh
the work ethic was always instilled into
me while my grandfather
and he he made it a point if you don't
work you don't eat and he meant that
you say you you go to school you work
you can eat you don't do those things
nothing's going to happen for you so I
had to make myself get on go to school
because where are your parents now my
parents well my mother's she passed away
and my father he and I aren't really
speaking
is he still involved in the no well he
he's changed his life you know
because their past well to be honest
with you I'm the son
of a pimp and a hole
and that's what it is and uh
I grew up pretty much being accustomed
to being around a lot of women you know
which was a good thing in a sense
because I had daughters when I grew up
so I was a little bit more sensitive to
you know what women need in that aspect
so I was more in tune with my daughters
because of the upbringing that I had
because I'm predominantly females that
you know raised me you know and are you
using drugs now uh I I smoke weed that's
about it that's it yeah
I think I do that too much
I mean people down here in Skid Row are
using something heavier well I I I've
had my you know experiences I've
experimented a whole lot of things LSD
cocaine and you know PCP but uh they're
not for me those things take me out of
my character and make me make unwise
decisions so I'll leave those things
alone
what happened to your eye oh well 1993 I
was assaulted in my sleep
a guy broke into a room that I had
rented
and he was attempting to rob me
so he hit me in the face with a lead
pipe as I was asleep
which caused me to lose my left eye
I've been shot stabbed
pretty much went through the ringer but
I'm still here
still alive
how do you support yourself now I'm
sorry how do you support yourself now oh
well I'm currently employed I work in a
medical office
and I make pretty decent money you know
just trying to save so I can better my
circumstance
you actually have a real legit job yes I
do and skid row no you're one of the
very few yes it's rare you know and it's
still it's still kind of strange that
you know my brother's gonna kill me when
you find when he sees this it's still
crazy that I live in a tent though you
know I mean although I have a generator
and like our propane tanks I have all
the conveniences and
but still it's not the same you know
from being in a you know a family
structure being in a home having a house
you know indoor plumbing to being in a
tent
it's a hell of a transition
do you think you've become accustomed to
the streets and that's why maybe you're
well Skid Row can make you complacent
because of all the
free stuff that you get or the things
that you you know normally would acquire
but say I can't afford it we don't pay
for a price down here for anything if
they make it too easy for it for
everybody
yes very comfortable yeah because when
people can literally lay down in one
spot
and know that a certain person is coming
on this particular day and have food
bought to them I mean literally brought
to them
yeah that would make a person you know
very complacent in clothes and shoes it
does you know it enables a lot of people
you know saying it's good for those who
really need it but a lot of us including
myself kind of take advantage of it you
know I haven't bought hygiene products
since 2014. why because they give it to
me for free every weekend you know I get
hygiene bags toothpaste soap socks and
you take a shower you go to the refresh
spot yeah so everything is like really
convenient it's like too easy so you
know if a person's getting a certain
income from you know or the Social
Security or GR
they that they mess up their money they
know for a full fact that hey I'm going
to have money I'll have food because I
can just go to the mission to eat I
don't have to worry about that I don't
have to worry about a shower I can go to
refresh spot you know that gives a
person to go ahead to you know [__] up
their money no bills no responsibilities
yeah you know because I know for a fact
that oh shoot it's the weekend they're
going to be passing out food at you know
this location or that location or I'll
just go to the missionary so it makes it
real easy for people it makes you well I
don't have to you know save money now
because I know that I got a meal coming
you know I'm not thinking about tomorrow
you know I'm saying tomorrow's taken
care of because I know for a fact I'm
going to the mission to eat clothes it
was before time my whole wardrobe came
from one of the missions down here and
it was pretty decent stuff that people
donate you know so people could where'd
you get that from when I tell them
they'd be like you're lying like no yeah
the clothes that are donated to the
missions here in L.A I mean name brand
interview I mean did that stress
homeless people you've ever seen Jordan
shoes I mean I I haven't wore anything
less than Jordans or Nikes since I've
been down here yeah because I can get
them I don't I don't pay for a price for
anything where you would go pay like
1500 for some shoes I get them for like
two or three hundred you know from
scooter skateboards on down bikes I
don't I don't pay for I don't pay a full
price for anything
if it makes no sense everything is half
price down here so it makes it you know
real comfortable for me you know you had
your life to live all over again if you
had your life to live all over again
Derek what would you do differently oh I
would change a whole I would change a
few things I would change a few things I
wouldn't have gotten involved in the
street life so much I would have really
just hunt you know bunker down and you
know did more studying and further my
education I should you know went to a
Collegiate level
no but I didn't so but I'm I'm content
you know
or would you like to be in five years
uh hopefully uh a business owner I'd
like to have my own
my own business you know working for
other people
it's not easy for me because I have to
you know be told what to do and listen
to somebody else's instruction instead
of going on my own Intuition or my own
you know knowledge you know because I
don't have letters behind my name though
doesn't mean that I don't know things
you know reading is fundamental if you
want to find out something there's so
many ways to you know acquire
information so
there's nothing that you can't know
about
Derek what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life how to mind your own business
instead of other people's affairs
you give yourself a chance for longevity
especially in this place and respect
that's the key to being down here is
respect if you have no respect for you
for others or yourself you won't last
even the mighty have fallen down here
I've seen some of the strongest get
taken out you're too hearty you know
you're too arrogant you feel that you're
untouchable but you can be touched
you know so I treat everybody
accordingly
I treat people the way I want to be
treated and I leave people alone
you know I'm on my own business
you know stay to myself I interact with
a few but for the most part I'm a Loner
you know and I don't
particularly care to be around a lot of
men I've always been that way
I prefer you know females you know I'm
comfortable like that okay I can deal
with females men they're
very strange now speaking as one you
know
they get [__] started and it's just a
mess and I don't have time for that
what was the roughest thing you went
through growing up the roughest thing
that I went through was watching my mom
and my dad
you know be overtaken by crack
you know
for to be able to rely on somebody and
you know that's my go-to mom and she's
always there
to a point where it's you know just here
take this money and get out of here
just go somewhere you know
it was it was a big difference you know
but thank God for my grandparents
because if it weren't for them I don't
think I'd be where I am now you know I
owe them
a great deal because without their
input and without their knowledge and
even though they didn't seem that I
listened I listened I heard them you
know because I see everything that they
told me
it's true to this very day and I miss
them so much because now I am the
grandfather you know I I don't have
anybody to go you know talk to or to you
know get you know family information
from now I'm the keeper of all that now
and that it's my responsibility so I
have to be a better person so I can show
my grandchildren
what an example of a man should be you
know whether they're my granddaughters
or my grandsons and I want them to be
proud of me and that's why I really am
working hard to change my life because I
don't want my legacy
to them to be the contents of my tent
you know and there's no honor in dying
in a tent what I want to do is die
around my grandchildren and my children
you know and hopefully get to say see
some great grandchildren
you know I have 11 grandchildren you
know I don't I haven't met them all
I hope to you know one day
yeah but the effects of crack cocaine
their
they they can last they can last for
Generations you know how many of your
friends growing up were impacted by
crack
anybody that grew up in sausage or La
any urban city that you lived in in
America
when
the president at the time allowed this
to happen
yeah we brought cocaine into the
neighborhoods he did us an injustice
a braver Injustice because
the family structure was was broken down
so for a man now to address a younger a
young man or you know or you know a
teenager it's like you can't tell me
what to do you're not my daddy because
we're not accustomed to having fathers
in the home so for for another man to
come and give us instruction we're not
going to listen to that this is not what
I'm accustomed to it was either my mom
or my grandma
you know and so if a woman says
something to me I'm more attentive I'm
more likely to respond and if a man says
the same I'll be like
who the hell are you you can't tell me
that so it it really destroyed the whole
family structure on how you know the
family should be it doesn't matter if
you're white or black it's just that our
family structure was destroyed so we
don't know how to have respect for our
elders we don't know how to treat people
you know the same way we look at each
other with disdain and hate and and then
it's sad but the power of the be
designed it like this they want us to be
pitted against each other so
we can destroy each other we'll help
them destroy us because that's exactly
what's happening and it's sad you know
and if you stand up and say well
Brothers we need to come together
sisters we need to come together
well they don't want that because that
does not go along with their narrative
so Gary eventually shot down or put in
jail or whatever the case may be but
you're eliminated because you're not
going along with the agenda and and I'm
realistic I know what's going on in this
world a lot of people would close their
eyes to the things that are happening I
see it I know what it is you know and we
always want to be quick to blame a white
man but and you could be you'd be
surprised the black people that are in
charge
those Elite people yeah and a lot of
people don't want to hear that but it's
true you know
so it's like we have to be more cautious
of our own kind you know I'm more
willing to trust somebody of A different
race and that's sad I should be able to
trust my own people but you can't
you know because they always have you
know an ulterior motive they're trying
to get
what you have they can have more than
you but they just don't want to see you
with anything you know I can't tell you
how many times I've been stolen from
down here you know and I don't steal
anything from anybody you know because I
don't mess with you or I'm not around
you I don't think I'm better than you
not in that aspect not just on a human
standpoint but and character and in
morals yes I am and I say that I am
better than you if you're stealing from
me I'm better than you you know
I am I work for mines I get up every day
I'll put in my eight hours
and I you know and while I'm gone y'all
stealing from me but it's good
because that's what makes me think no
that's what makes me know that I'm
better than you because I'm not stealing
from you you want what I got I need
nothing from you
all right Derek thank you so much for
sharing your story I appreciate you
thank you wish you the best of luck out
there